Herkese merhabalar Bu benim 5 sene
önceki cvm Yani biraz geride kalmış bir
CV ama yine de ne kadar gereksiz bir
adam olduğunun yine en büyük
kalıplarından bir tanesi Eee köprü
dünyada üzerine en çok konuşulan
metaforlu
büyük bir ihtimalle bir de ben yarım
saat önce geldim herhalde Şu ana kadar
yapılan konuşmaların büyük bir çoğunluğu
benim zaten anlatacaklarımı anlatmış
olabilir Eğer böyle bir şey varsa özür
diliyorum iki şey yapmaya çalışacağım
birincisi size görünen Köprüler sunum
buradaymış
pardon görünen Köprüler diğeri de
görünmeyen Köprüler hakkında biraz
konuşmak istiyorum bir sosyal bilimci
olduğum için eee bir eğitim bilimci
olmadığı için ama eğitime meraklı bir
sosyal bilimci olduğum için genelde
Eee köprü metaforunu düşünürken Acaba
hangi bağlantıları kuruyor kimi nereden
nereye geçiriyor köprüyü geçerken bu eee
etkinliğin teması olduğu için bunları da
düşünmeye gayret ettim Bu sunumu
hazırlarken Tabii türkçemizin en güzel
deyimlerinden bir tanesi
Eee köprüyle ilgili
Eee köprüye Köprüyü geçene kadar benim
başlığım Ama bunu birkaç kişiye anlattım
dün de anlattım Köprüyü geçene kadar
dedim insanlar bana hemen Aa Köprüyü
geçene kadar ayıyı ayıya Dayı demek
deyimini mi anlatacaksın dediler Eee ben
de hiç değilse başta koyayım da
insanların gönlü kalmasın dedim ama
gerçekten güzel ve Türkçenin şu an yani
Türkiye'nin bugün itibariyle insanların
arası insanlar arası ilişkilerini büyük
oranda Bence özetleyen bir negatif ama
pejoratif ve pejoratif bir Eee deyimi
bize Eee gösteriyor insanların işleri
bitene kadar
biraz da suistimal kokan hareketlerle
birbirleriyle ilişkiler kurması
samimiyetten uzak olması ve köprünün
işte şeyine geçtikten sonra diğer
tarafına geçtikten sonra işlerin
bittiğini anlatan Bence güzel bir deyim
benim bundan sonra anlatmak istediğim
köprüyü geçerken kavramının ne kadar
gereksiz bir kavram
olduğu Dediğim gibi ben bir sosyal
bilimciye tarihi yazılsa nasıl bir tarih
olur insan zaman ve mekan bileşenleri
ışığında bir tarih yazsak nasıl yazarız
falanı düşündüm ve Evet Hani şimdi çok
moda bir kavram var 4 endüstri çağına
giriyoruz 1 2 3 Onların hepsinin birer
köprü inşa projesi inşa modeli inşa
mühendisliği buna bir yaklaşımları var
statik olarak kültürel olarak vesaire
ama acaba içine girdiğimiz Çağ gerçekten
köprüleri geçiyor
muyuz sadece köprüleri geçiyor muyuz
köprüleri sadece geçmek için mi
kullanıyoruz Bir de buna bakarken Tabii
sosyal bilimci büyük resmi görecek ya
hani köprü sadece mimari bir yapı değil
aynı zamanda diş tedavisinde kullanılan
bir kavram güreşte hani tam tuş ederken
getirdiğiniz pozisyonun adı da köprü
gitarda Sinan abi daha iyi bilir o
Tellerin klavyeye durmasını sağlayan bir
şey hani hav imanına giderken bir
havalimanına gittiğimizde Uçağa binerken
bir yerden geçiyoruz ya Onun adı da
köprü köprü genelde kullanılan bir
kavram yakaları bağlıyor iki Yakayı
birbirine bağlıyor Hatta kıtaları
bağlıyor birbirine kültürleri bağlıyor
bazen kültürleri birbirlerinden
koparıyor Bence Mostar Köprüsü Bunlardan
en önemli bunların en
önemli örneklerinden bir tanesi
hırvatlar mimaran Es olan veya çırağının
eseri olan Mostar
köprüsünü ki biz onu kültürler bağlansın
diye Herhalde bizim geçmişimizde bu
yapılmış Ama hırvatlar bunu 1993 yılında
yıktılar yani bağlıyor birbirinden
ayırıyor Hatta Köprüler korkuları
yendiren böyle camdan Köprüler
yapıyorlar insanlar üzerinden geçerken
düşeceğini falan zannediyor yükseklik
korkusu olan insanlar iki tane kızcağız
herhalde arkadaşlarını çeke çeke diğer
tarafa götür çalışıyorlar zorlukları
açtırıyor
insanlara özellikle Anadolu'nun birçok
yerinde Benim de ailemin bir tarafı
Anadolulu babamdan çok dinledim bu
hikayeyi yani okula giderken Hadi
ilkokula gittin köyde Ondan sonra
ortaokula giderken işte ilçeye
gideceksin Bilmem neden geçeceksin bir
dereyi aşacaksın bir çayı aşısıni zorluk
tarafı var Okula da götürüyor tabii yani
köprünün önemli özelliklerinden bir
tanesi öğrenci okula götürmesi kimi
zaman da onları öldürüyor böyle bir şey
de var bir sosyal bilimci gözüyle
baktığınız zaman okul yılında ölüm
Köprüsü lafa
bak Bunun pili bitti
galiba Bunlar görünen Köprüler ya bir
sosyal teori yazsam kültürel ve sosyal
teori yazsam köprü hakkında bunları
söylerim böyle hızlı hızı geçeyim
görünmeyen Köprüler neler aşk sevgi
muhabbet herkesin çok bildiği Sırat
köprüsü geçeceğiz görmedik Yani bir
köprü var Nasıl bir köprü çok sevdim ben
bunu
ya ama sonunda söylem Yani eğer
bağlayabilir söylemek istediğim şeyin
bir özeti de bu
aslında ben Sırat köprüsünde seiz diğer
arkadaşla beraber Ulan dur diyor
geçiyoruz düşmeden geçelim de arkadaş
bir tanesi de geçmiş bu da görünmeyen
bir köprü inananlar inanıyor
inanmayanlar inanmıyor vesaire deli
dumrul'un bir köprüsü var hiç dinlediniz
mi Bunun hikayesini muhteşem bir
hikaye Deli Dumrul geçenden 30
geçmeyenden 40 akçe aldığı bir köprü var
biliyor musunuz Kaç kişi duydu Deli
Dumrul hikayesini biliyorsunuz değil mi
Deli dumrul'un işte bir köprüsü var
yanında bir Oba çadır şey kuruyor kamp
kuruyor Oba kuruluyor Daha doğrusu kamp
lafa bak Oba ve
Kamp birisi ölüyor niye öldü işte Allah
öldürdü kim nasıl öldü işte Azrail geldi
getirin lan bu Azrail'i bana diyor Nasıl
bir Azrail'i nasıl öldürür falan Ondan
sonra Onun da bir cebelleşmek var ama
bence hayata dair insan zaman mekan
kurgusunda geçmişe dönerek biraz
baktığımız zaman Eee bize çok dersler
verecek bir köprü hikayesi Mars'a
gidiyoruz tamam uzay kö şeyden
fırlatılıyor uzay Mekke'ye gidiyor
konuyor insanlar Hatta işte dün el musk
açıkladı spacex'in ve Tesla'nın sahibi
dedi ki 2024'te marsay Ama bu da bir
köprü yolc Yani bir yerden bir yere
gidiyorsun arada bir köprü var teknoloji
yazılım vesaire burayı tanıyan var
mı neresi Martin Savur savur'dan bir
köprüyle bir köprü vasıtasıyla bu eğitim
olabilir gayret olabilir Çok güzel bir
laf söylemiş geçen Aziz Bey demiş ki ben
zekaya falan inanmıyorum
arkadaş çalışma ya Çok çalışırsan benim
Geldiğim yere gelebilirsin ama Aziz
Bey'in de bir hikayesi var benim de bir
hikayem var Karagümrük'te doğdum
oxford'da
okudum baktığım zaman birbirine çok her
zaman anlatırım çok zıt iki yapı yani
Birisi bravado delikanlılık Efendim işte
hani Abi ne yapıyorsun bugün
işte
akşam maça gideceğiz Anladın
mı Karagümrük lehçesi bu eski
katoliklerin yaşadığı Bizans döneminde
bugün vef hastad autus sarnıcının
bulunduğu kauo müzesinin eski karye
Kilisesi ve camisinin yani şehir dışında
kalan demek Yunancada ama beni oraya
taşıyan bir köprü de var Hep üzerine
düşündüğüm daha pek şey yapamadığım bir
başka köprü mesela Müzik Hani geriz
müzik falan dedi Ben müzisyen değilim
ama hayatımın çoğunu perküsyon çalarak
çalmaya çalışarak
geçirdim ya burada hayatım işte 5 10 15
20 yaşındayken bana özellikle 10'lu ve
20'li yaşlarımda düyek evfer Frank Çin
Devri Kebir evsat nim evsat diye usuller
Öğrettiler yüzlerce usul onlarca usul Ya
ben bunları ne yapacağım dedim oxford'a
mülakata gittiğimde dediler ki ne
yaparsın sen tamam dedim ben işte yazı
yazarım falan başka ne yaparsın arkadaş
dediler ha dedim ben müzik ble bendir
falan kudüm çalarım usul vururum falan
büyük usul böyle 64 zamanlı falan Okey
geç
bakalım ve oraya gittiğimde Oxford'un
en ünlü öğrenci grubunda enig jones'
kabul edildim perküsyonist olarak ve 4
yıl sayıları 100 ile 7.000 8.000 10.000
izleyici olan büyük giger yaptık büyük
konserler verdik Bence bu da görünmeyen
köprülerden bir tanesi müzik o önümde
Duran sazın adı kudum eski bir Türkiye
Türk müziğinde özellikle Eee Türk
müziğinde kondüktör bir sa yani Şef yok
o zaman o usul vuruyor Herkes ona uyuyor
bir gün size bir usul vururum büyük
Devri Kebir nasıl fırlıyor falan kantarı
mecaz bu lafı Duydunuz mu görünmeyen
köprülerden bir tanesi bu göremezsiniz
Google'da bile Arayınca çıkmıyor öyle
enteresan bir laf bir divan
edebiyatı kavramı kantari mecaz Kantara
köprü demek kantarı mecaz mecaz Köprüsü
demek Ne işe
yarar Hazreti Mevlana'nın çok güzel bir
lafı var bence çok önemli bir laf mecaz
hakikatin köprüsüdür öyle matriksi falan
seyredince işinde a içinde tasavvuf var
içinde Kabala var ya Yok ulan işte adam
Yazmış Başka bir şey yazmış Adam Matrix
yani sayılar akıyor gidiyorsun falan ama
öyle ya bırak sen başka bir şey var
orada Adam mecazdan film yapmış senin
yaptığın filmlere bakınca hani o
mecazdan çıkıp filmler yapıyoruz ya hani
bir tür kantarı mecaz bir tür Leyla'dan
mevlaya geçme Fas Yani öyle bir MFÖ
şarkısı var ya buna benzer bir laf ama
çok önemli bir laf genelde geçtiği yer
neresi biliyor musunuz Hayret Vadisi
diye eski tasavvufi literatürde Divan
edebiyatında Bir vadi var Kaf dağının
arkası Hayret Vadisi kimse ne olduğunu
bilmiyor ama bir vadi var işte zorluklar
var vesaire böyle bir
tekamüle yarayan tekamülü sembolize eden
bir köprü bu Çünkü bizim
oksidental kültürden farkımız şu Bizim
köprülerimiz tekamül ettirir batının
köprüleri fark kapatır bring the GAP
Crossing bizim köprülerimiz
toprakların Köprüsü nostaljik ve
romantik konuşmuyorum bir hakikatten
bahsediyorum Tekamül ettirir köprü bizde
Tekamül için
vardır Eski dünya görünen Köprüler
görünmeyen Köprüler böyle bir
yer bugünün köprüleri bambaşka Köprüler
görünmüyor bu Köprüler hiçbir tanesi bu
wi-fi'ler falan filan Hiçbirimiz
görmüyoruz ama Wifi var ya radyo
frekansı da vardı e vardı da radyo
frekansı var olduğu
günlerde Günde 400 milyar bilmem ne
mesaj atılıp 7 milyar Emoji
paylaşılmıyor falan başka bir yerdeyiz
Bu açıdan bakıldığında
ülkelerin dünya nüfusuna bakışımız
değişti Bugün kime sorsanız biraz kafası
çalışan dünyanın en kalabalık ülkesi
hangisi Facebook diyor abi akıllı adam
Çünkü çünkü Orası bir ülke her zaman
anlattığım hikayedir Facebook bir
ülkedir Kosova gibi küçük bir Devleti
tanıdığı zaman 2 yıl
önce çok dikkat ediniz kosova'yı 102
ülke tanır diğerleri tanımaz 198 tane
Birleşmiş Milletler üye ülke var
kosova'yı Facebook ülke olarak tanıdı ne
demek bu bir Sırp yani Ülkesi Egemen
sovereign State olarak tanımadığı yan
komşu reddettiği ülkeyi adam Facebook'ta
Kosova olarak görüyor Çünkü ıp'ler başka
şeyler dönüyor arkasında sanal
gerçekliğe giden Köprüler var Bakın bu
Gözlüklerin hepsi birer köprü hiç
taktınız mı bilmiyorum ben de hani bu
kadar teknoloji dijitalle ilgilenen
birisiyim ama yeni taktım Geçen hafta
gerçekten bambaşka bir şey ve iş oraya
doğru
gidiyor sanal gerçeklikte selfiler
çekiliyor artık dünyanın ilk sanal
selfisi Bu geçen gün Facebook'un
zuckerberg'in tanıttığı Facebook'un
geliştirici konferansında yani
yazılımcıların Facebook'a yaptıkları
katkıları anlattıkları konferansın
içinde çekilen görüntüler ve bu son e
kpc Dün de çok Ben geçen gün çok sık
şekilde bunu söyledim bu köprüleri
anlamamız lazım nedir bu Köprüler
Snapchat bugün
Twitter'ın üye sayısını geçti 140 milyon
Twitter aktif günlük kullanıcı sayısı
Snapchat kullanıcı sayısı 150 kurulma
zamanlarına bakıyorsunuz Snapchat
Twitter'dan yaklaşık kaç sene bilmiyorum
34 sene sonra kurulmuş 2000 işte
herhalde 11'de kuruluyor Twitter daha
önce en az 45 sene önce kuruluyor ama ne
oluyor Bir geliş bir kullanıcı
artırımı
yüz lerce sene içerisinde telefon
dediğimiz cihaz
bakın 100 milyon kullanıcıya ulaştı ama
Candy Crush oyunu çıktığı günün 2 hafta
sonrasında 100 milyon kullanıcıya
ulaşmıştı çünkü başka Köprüler
kullanıyordu algoritmik şunu geçmeyeyim
algoritmik Köprüler Bunlar fiziki
Köprüler değil algoritmik Köprüler
bunlar öyle algoritmik Köprüler ki kıvai
köprüsünü hatırlarsınız Savaş millet
birbirini bombalamak için uğraşıyor
askerler Japonlar İngiliz askerleri
subayları bugün Siber savaşlar oluyor
Hiç böyle İstihkam taburları falan filan
yok Ne var Siber ordular var nerede Bu
herifler bilgisayarın başında var mı bir
köprü
ekibi yok Sadece Pizza sipariş ediyorlar
kapıya gelen Doritos şeyci var Dominos
Pizzacı var köprü olarak
değerlendirirseniz adamların kullandığı
tek İstihkam meselesi kapıya getirilen
yemek çünkü adam bilgisayarın başından
kalkmıyor köprü yaptıran oyunlar var
bugün çok
enteresan o algoritmik köprüleri
kullanarak gerçekliğe biraz sırası
yanlış olabilir bu slaytın Ama
gerçekliğe doğru çok gidiş yani sanal
dünyada gerçekliğe doğru şiddetli bir
gidiş var bir yöneliş var koby brind
basketbola başladığında bilgisayar
oyunundaki haliyle koby brind bilgisayar
basket buu bıraktığında herhangi bir
dijital oyundaki durum Arasında dağlar
kadar fark var diyeceksiniz ki bu grafik
Evet grafik siz biz Oturup bunu
yapabiliriz ama mesele bunun arkasındaki
algoritmik köprüyü anlayabilmek
anlamıyoruz arkadaş bu ülkede Bu kültür
gelişmiyor algoritmik Kültür ne yapalım
okullarda kodlama Yok
ya okullarda kodlamayı öğreterek Tamam
Herkes kodlayıcı artık okullarda müzik
öğretiyoruz ne oluyor okullarda edebiyat
öğretiyoruz ne oluyor konuşuyor musunuz
çok iyi Türkçe yazabiliyor
musunuz Onun için fikir köprüdür iyi
fikirler çok sağlam
köprülerdeki
çıkmıyor mu çıkıyor tabii ki Çünkü
genetik
mühendisliği buna izin veriyor bunun
için çalışıyor ama genetik mühendisliği
de Komünikasyon ve bilgisayar ve
algoritmik yapılardan destekleniyor daha
önce hiç olmadığı şekilde destekleniyor
hem de ve gerçek zamanlı Köprüler Bunlar
insanlar arasındaki bağlantılar çok sıkı
bağlantılar iki ekrandan 5 ekrana Doğru
giden bir gençlik bir bir nesilden
bahsediyoruz böyle çok hani Türkiye'de a
x y z kuşağı Hani göster diyorsun bir
tane Z kuşağını bana x kuşağını ya Benim
evdeki çocuk yok ya Bu kadar basit değil
bu işler Tamam Bunlar birer
kategorizasyon birer abstraksiyon birer
soyutlama Ama bu insanları ölçüyor muyuz
Bu İnsanları biçiyor muyuz Bu İnsanları
inceliyor muyuz gözlemliyor muyuz Hayır
ama evet bu işle uğraşan insanlar
diyorlar ki Z kuşağı 5 ekran Peki bu 5
ekranla beraber başa çıkmasını sağlayan
Köprüler neler hangi
beceriler ve günde 7 milyar Emoji Evet
günde 7 milyar Emoji paylaşılıyor bugün
emojiler birer köprü mü Evet birer köprü
kulakları içın Levent AB Levent Erdin
hayatında dünyada şu ana kadar en belki
be tane izlemişimdir en iyi Emoji
sunumunu yapmıştır muhakkak bulmanız bu
adamı bulun ve bir yerde Dinleyin bu
emojiler çok önemli bir sosyal teori var
arkasında Bir kültürel teori
var ve gerçek zamanlılık gerçek zamanlı
gidiş resim de eskiden sadece canlı
yayın vardı televizyonda bugün artık
başka bir yapı var açıyorsun telefonu
Ben de şimdi açabilirim tak bir
basıyorsun abi ha canlı Yayındayız
hepimiz Şimdi başka bir şey var Snapchat
ben çok hiç kullanmadım Hatta ama
bambaşka bir yapı var Orada orada
insanları tatmin eden insanların günlük
ihtiyaçlarını karşılayan bambaşka bir
dünya var bir tür sokak sanatı işlerin
sokak sanatı haline gelmesi istikrar
sürdürülebilirlik yok bu kavramlar
bitiyor bu kavramlara çok güvenmeyin bu
kavramlara çok İtimat etmeyin
sustainability falan bunlar geleceğin
kavramı değil gerçekten değil sokak
sanatı burada yapayım Snapchat
diğer sokağa gideyim başka bir Snapchat
basayım nerede sürdürülebilirlik
sürdürülebilirliğe göre benim orada ki
durumumu ve Konumumu statik şeklinde
koruyabilmek için benim bir strateji
geliştirmem lazım
Hayır ve öğrenme köprüsü Bizim bu ülkede
biraz bir okuldayız Tabii Burası
Türkiye'nin çok Seçkin bir Okulu yüzde
ne yüzdesi belki 10 binde Birlik bir
bölümde olan bir
okul 10 binde birlik bu anlattıklarımı
gidip başka bir yerde anlatmam için
herhangi Birinizin gidip orada
anlatabilmesi için çok sıkı bir tercüman
kullanması
lazım ama hepimizi ilgilendiren bir
sorun var O da bu ülkede öğrenme
köprülerine ihtiyacımız var Çünkü bu
ülkede eğitim kavramı artık
bir boş bir kavram haline geldi eğitim
ve öğrenme arasındaki köprüleri kur
kurabilmemiz lazım bireyselleşme
konusunda biraz daha zaman ve kafa
harcamamız lazım Tasarımın ve kullanıcı
tecrübesinin arasındaki
farkın eğitim ve öğrenme arasındaki
farkla çok ilişkili olduğunu
bireyselleşmenin bunlarla çok ilişkili
olduğunu anlamamız lazım Başka çaremiz
yok ve öyle Köprüler kurmalıyız ki biz
dünyada eğitim düzeyi okullaşma kalite
falan konuşurken 18-24 yaş grubu
Zannederim arasında dünyanın en fazla
okula devam etmeme oranına sahip ülke
olmayalım Bunun için de bir köprü lazım
ama Görünen bir köprü değil Tamam çok
güzel görünen Köprüler icra attır
vesairedir ama bizim daha çok görünmeyen
köprülere ihtiyacımız var ki içeriği
biraz geliştirebilirim ve 4 endüstri
devrimi bunun köprüleri gerçekten çok
ilginç olacak uzmanları konuşmalı Bence
bunu Sonuç olarak benim söylemek
istediğim ben köprüleri geçmeye
inanmıyorum Ben köprülerde yaşamaya
inanıyorum Bence geleceğin hayatı
köprülerde yaşamak köprülerde yaşamayı
öğrenmek mecazları kaybediyoruz
anlatmaya çalıştığım görünen ve
görünmeyen Köprüler arasındaki kültür
teorisi veya denemesi veya Kırıntısı
müsvettesi ne derseniz
deyin hakikatler imizi kaybediyoruz Bunu
hiçbir ideolojik şeyle bağlamayın
hakikatin en saf anlamından bahsediyorum
hakikat şudur bir su dolu bardağa
baktığınızda içindeki bardağı kırık
gördüğünüzde Bu bir doğrudur ama o bir
hakikat değildir Çünkü Hakikatte O
bardak kır O kalem kırık değildir işte
bunun arasındaki farkları anlayabilme
kabiliyetler imizi kaybediyoruz
köprülerimiz yapmıyoruz köprülerimiz
yıkıyoruz Çünkü bizi birbirimize
bağlayan değerler mecazlar kavramlar
kantari mecazları hakikat mecazları bir
şekilde kaybediyoruz sonra da en sonunda
şikayet ediyoruz ve o şikayetlerle
yaşıyoruz mesaş benim buradan
çıkartacağım kendi adıma çıkarttığım bu
konuşmayı hazırlarken bu paketi
hazırlarken sonucum o bence köprüleri
geçmeyelim köprülerde yaşayalım ve
yaşamayı öğrenelim onlar Çünkü hayatın
yeni yaşam alanları çok teşekkür
ediyorum sağ olun
for